AGREEMENT FRIDAY TO PLEAD BILL T
TO CONSPIRACY TO DEFRAUD THE
UNITED STATES AND LYING TO THE
FBI.
>> Bret: THE EFFORT TO STOP
ANOTHER PARKLAND OR COLUMBINE OR
SANDY HOOK FROM HAPPENING IS THE
TOP JOB FOR CONGRESS.
CHIEF CONGRESSIONAL
CORRESPONDENT MIKE MANUAL TELLS
US OF ANYTHING SUBSTANTIAL IS
HAPPENING ON GUN CONTROL AND
SCHOOL SAFETY.
>> STUDENTS FROM MARJORY
STONEMAN DOUGLAS HIGH SCHOOL
TOOK TO CAPITOL HILL THEIR
MESSAGE.
A MESSAGE NOT LOST ON SPEAKER
PAUL RYAN WHO SEEMED CONFLICTED
OVER PRESIDENT TRUMP'S PUSH ON
ARMING TEACHERS TO MAKE AMERICAN
SCHOOLS SAFER.
>> AS A PARENT AND AS A CITIZEN,
I THINK IT'S A GOOD IDEA BUT AS
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE I NEED TO
RESPECT FEDERALISM AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS.
>> DEMOCRATS BACKED A PROPOSAL
TARGETING FIREARMS LIKE THE ONE
USED IN PARKLAND.
>> WELL OVER 150 PEOPLE
SUPPORTING IT.
THAT'S PRETTY CLEAR.
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF THE
HOUSE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS.
>> THE IDEA IS A NONSTARTER FOR
REPUBLICANS.
THE PROPOSAL THAT HAS THE MOST
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT TIGHTENING OF
BACKGROUND CHECKS BY
INCENTIVIZING STATES AND FEDERAL
AGENCIES TO SEND INFORMATION TO
THE NATIONAL INSTANT CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND CHECK SYSTEM.
FACT BY TEXAS REPUBLICAN JOHN
CORNYN AND CONNECTICUT DEMOCRAT
CHRIS MURPHY.
>> I AM ENCOURAGED THAT THE
PRESIDENT SEEMS TO BE WILLING TO
DO SOMETHING ON BACKGROUND
CHECKS.
HE HAS ENDORSED ONLINE
CONFERENCE OF BACKGROUND CHECKS.
>> CHUCK SCHUMER WANTS A FULL
DEBATE ON GUN ISSUES AND SAYS
JUST BACKGROUND CHECKS WON'T CUT
IT.
>> IF THAT'S ALL CONGRESS DOES,
WE WON'T HAVE DONE OUR JOB TO
KEEP AMERICA'S FAMILIES SAFE.
>> SENATE MAJORITY LEADER
MITCH MCCONNELL NOTES THE GUN
ISSUE BRINGS OUT PASSIONS.
>> WAVED WE HAVE BEEN DOWN
>> WAVED WE HAVE BEEN DOWT
>> WAVED WE HAVE BEEN DOWI
>> WAVED WE HAVE BEEN DOWS
>> WAVED WE HAVE BEEN DOWP
>> WAVED WE HAVE BEEN DOWT
>> WAVED WE HAVE BEEN DOWH
BEFORE.
THERE ARE BIPARTISAN DIFFERENCES
ABOUT HOW TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE.
>> MCCONNELL SAYS THE FOCUS OF
REPUBLICAN SENATORS WAS ON
SCHOOL SAFETY AND NOT GUNS.
DEMOCRATS CLEARLY WORRIED
REPUBLICANS WILL PASS THE